we're talking with Angie and Connecticut
hey Angie how are you thank you
all right you know one more time you
said your job was what you were stuck in
New York apt or what right so what I
wanted to know was so basically where I
am right now my salary is going to be
capped at where I am I'm not moving any
further because I don't have any other
what do I say I guess college education
or anything else because currently right
now where I am has to do with nursing
and I'm not a nurse I'm on the
administrative side and so I came across
I always like to do or I'd like to be
involved in trade field type of work I
actually enjoy plumbing and I came
across a wonderful apprenticeship
program that's actually a paid program
for five years so my question is this
being that we're currently working on
baby step number two even though I'm
taking two steps back to do this
apprenticeship program what it makes
sense to go on with it or completely be
debt-free and then do this program three
years later it's going to take you three
years to get out of that well because
currently right now we're just about
40,000 and that you're single no no my
husband and I so we currently our
household income is 65 of the year in
your $40,000 in debt okay so y'all be
out of debt in two years not three
hustling would be the plan right okay so
all right so we're gonna hustle we're
gonna get out of debt and to you so what
do you currently make myself 45 and so
your husband makes $20,000 right because
he's part-time because we also have two
little children and we don't pay for
childcare because it would be more than
what we would I even bring in really Oh
and so you would go for as the primary
breadwinner from 45 to what on this
apprentice well currently I'm seeing
here that it will be anywhere between 15
85 an hour saying that it would give you
a percentage of what the journeyman wage
rate would be but it does say that the
wage rate does advance yearly as you
continue to get more under your belt
under the apprenticeship program if
you're getting fortified where you get
40 hours yes it does it's Monday through
Friday classes it's 40 hours and it does
see at the end of this completion you
get a certificate from the state of
which I live
as a licensed diploma because it pays
about 35 grand if you only work 40 hours
could you do a side hustle do you mean
not being a trade um okay
let me see her probably cannot because
it's saying that I would need to do two
night classes from 6:00 p.m. to 9:00
p.m. and that would be Thursdays and
Tuesday nights but I have to attend and
that's part of their service are you're
how old 42 and when you're 52 you want
to be a plumber I do okay I think you're
reading a brochure to me and I think
that's the only knowledge you have of
this program I want you to do more
investigation and I want you to learn
every detail of the program and I want
you to keep working to get out of debt
and somewhere close to the point that
you're out of debt like 18 months from
now maybe you would start the program no
I would not take that much of a step
back today to not make that much of a
step forward later and it because it's
going to extend the time you're in debt
substantially of course anything as soon
as you're out of debt you can do it so
any side hustle you can pick up now
anything your husband can do to increase
his income now while you're doing all
this to get you out of debt that much
faster because soon as you're free of
debt it gives you lots of options
there's lots of different things you can
do at that point and so that's um that's
the plan then and that's what I would do
so hey thanks for the call